golf may have found its next big star on
Sunday 21 year-old jordan Spieth one of
the Masters with a score that tied a
record low at Augusta who's he tied with
none other than Tiger Woods with us now
the 2015 Masters Tournament winner
Jordan Smith Jordan what a week what a
weekend congratulations thank you very
much
the last 48 hours what has it been like
craziest thing that's happened to you I
think just the the craziness in New York
just coming up here and going through
coming on your show and and just
enjoying wearing this jacket around and
what it means and the legacy that it
carries just being introduced as a
Masters winner it's crazy in itself here
you are you're 21 years old and you have
just achieved your lifelong dream what
do you do now how do you reset well I
haven't figured that out yet but
ultimate goal is to become number one in
the world Rory McIlroy is number one in
the world right now this is a really a
giant step towards that but that's the
next goal that's always on my mind that
that eventually is that is a long-term
goal but I'm glad to be off to a good
start with it well everybody wants to
know what was on your mind this weekend
specifically Sunday the back nine you
weren't playing to not lose you stepped
up and you said I want to play to win
that's right you didn't need to do that
here in New York we remember when Phil
Mickelson played at the US Open at
Wingfoot took a risk like that and
really whiffed why would you do that
well last year 2014 I had the lead on
Sunday at the Masters I then played not
to lose I played a little more
conservative what's not Who I am and the
course bit me and Bubba Watson went and
became the champion he came back and
took it over this year I learned from
that and said I need to stick to Who I
am if I don't pull off the shots then
it's bad execution but I don't want to
change my decision-making based on you
know I wanted to continue what was
successful that week and that's what we
did he said it's not who you are then
who are you describe yourself as a
golfer in one word aggressive
just kind of young fearless is what I'd
like to be said you know I like to take
chances not be scared of the next shot
because that's how you learn that's how
you learn who you are is that why you
signed with Under Armour because that's
often how we describe we hear Under
Armour district's one of the many
reasons yes yeah I mean they're fearless
they're aggressive and you know
obviously they're I believe they're the
best in the game but you know and and
they certainly are for me now we see
pictures of you and you're wearing Under
Armour not just on the course in your
free time we see your dad your brother
are you living this brand how important
is that to you sure yeah it's it's meant
the world to me the chance that they
took when I left school and came out
with no status on tour and then to Reese
I'm with them for them to put their
trust in me for 10 more years starting
the beginning of this year they expect
greatness from everybody that's involved
in the company including myself and I'm
happy to be a part of it I'm happy to be
a you know as much or a little as as
they want me to be but to be very
involved with the whole process of
determining what I wear how to be
comfortable and to then perform my best
and not worry about anything else this
is incredible they also don't make
equipment was it a factor for you when
Rory signed with Nike and had to change
equipment it hurt his game you still
play with Titleist clubs did that matter
to you no it actually was helpful yeah I
didn't have to change anything I didn't
want to change anything on course in
making this transition it was going to
be hard enough already
it was a life change so to be able to
just wear clothes that I already wore
anyways and to play the same clubs that
I already played it made that transition
just a little easier so many people out
there want their sons want their
daughters to be these premier athletes
help us understand when you were a kid
who are you playing for how much time
were you putting in
I played all sports my parents just
encouraged us if we wanted to be really
good at something to set goals that's
what my dad always told me to do write
down a goal that you want to achieve
that was really important but it was
never pushed to play golf I wanted to
play all sports I think it's the best
route for kids these days figure out
what you love
find a group of friends that love it
that are you're gonna push each other
and if you if that's what you want to do
for a living then it's gonna take a lot
of hard work where does the mental
strength come from though there's no
team you can't the ball you can't tag
out well I love the fact that we control
our own destiny our preparation and
practice determines how we perform on
the course you'll have to rely on
anybody else you're playing against your
mind in the golf course and so whether
you either have the determination or you
don't to begin with and having success
then kind of brings more and more out
and more confidence out to go on in the
future that what makes you so good at
ping pong that's my game it's not golf
that's your game that's my game